[Music]
what do you want to talk about Bobby
what do you want to talk about today
well how about culture I'm saying
culture must have presented itself as a
barrier between Neanderthals and humans
remember humans are coming out of Africa
they're going into Europe right they're
nomadic the nano-cells are sedentary you
know they're there in their own turf
they've been there five hundred thousand
years we're invading down
so we're migrants you know and they're
not they're settlers settlers but that's
among the other thing but there's a
couple more like did we have a one-night
stand was it was it just a couple of
incidences were maybe a nanslo raped a
woman or something like that
well I got through the culture yeah it's
got to do with culture because the
question is what was the family type
what was the mentality of Amanda so I'll
try to we're trying to think you know
put our brains in his brain can't figure
out what do you think did would he go
out there and rape a woman or would he
have long-term relationships with humans
what were the buddies were they
neighbors were they friendly neighbors
and they said yeah come join the bounty
of the land we're gonna hunt together
you said that they were neighbors baby
well we call it an invasion it's a
migration and I assume each other
well again admixture claims that they
saw each other they did a little more
and so what what I'm putting on the line
here is whether the cultures of the hue
of humans and Neanderthals worried
whether it permitted for them to mingle
be neighbors and friends
the end you know out there in the wild
right did they hunt together then were
the beer buddies did they swap wives or
were they an amazing I'm gonna kill you
I mean what was their relationship in
that sense culture does play a role you
know why is there been tapped
what role does culture play in the
neighborliness of these two species well
look from this point of view they
discovered they discovered that from
such different bones right that nando
though did engage at one point or
another in cannibalism yeah they cut
their own people you know they see chop
marks in the bones that they said this
wasn't done by a tiger this was done by
an and I thought who who were trying to
get to the bone marrow of his own kind
so now think about that for a second
here's this ate this monkey I mean if if
you visualize them like I do this and
they eat my monkey and Arctic gorillas
chimpanzees also eat each other not that
they do and so and so the question is
there's this guy who does cannibalism he
kills mammoths with a with teamwork you
know there's maybe 10 15 20 guys that go
out there with their spears and they
fooled the animal and they stab him they
kill him they all eat he's looking this
very you know basil type of life he's
got he's he's really a very prehistoric
type of hunter-gatherer and to think
that this guy would exhume kind would
accept an invading group of animals
which he obviously regardless of
different species you would they mingle
where they say okay come on you you can
sleep with my wife today and I'll sleep
with yours you know it's it's very hard
to believe the culture would stand in
the way of such a rugged species that
you know that thinks of only the basics
of only killing some animal
and living one more day from there to
extrapolate that they would invite
humans in they had a great party does it
have to be an invitation like it can be
animosity and still have intermingling
without rape necessarily there was there
was fighting you the worst enemy of the
earth or was another name but then but
then you got a look at what was the
family structure what was a culture like
and that's what I'm getting at I'm
saying one way of figuring that out is
to look at the great apes that we have
today
what kind of societies do they have you
know you got the gorillas he's got a
patriarchal society where you know he's
the dominant silverback he's the
dominant guy right and he's got his
harem the chimps they don't have that
same situation they have a kind of like
a fatherly figure who's not the
strongest but the smartest the diamond
can manipulate you
you've got the orangutans and they're
solitary they're like the Tigers you
know there's one right man he's got
several women several females and they
take care of their own regions and he
kind of visits all of them so they all
have these different structures the
question what was the structure of the
Neanderthals you would think that if
they had some kind of clan structure
which is more than likely what kind of
sex that they have well the sex that it
is is is is already theorized that they
had group sex that everybody slept with
everybody father can sleep with daughter
you know everything was fair game
all females were fair game right and you
would think that at least the
hunter-gatherers were more like the Apes
that the chimp the gorillas the chance
to orangutan where they had maybe you
know a father you're a macho figure an
alpha male or whatever and they all
hunted together and they lived in a cave
you would think that it's like a clan
structure and that's a very close in in
society because that's the country
that's the flag that's the National
and that group you fight and you die you
live for the clan and you plan on the
other side each other whoa no you would
eat someone on the other side of the
river he's your enemy and now they're
eating their own family I don't know I
don't think so I think they they killed
someone from the other plan across the
street they were enemies in that sense
and if you've got this situation where
the feet end you know the way they form
new clans is you know the youngsters the
teenagers they need the clan and they go
off and so do females lead the clan and
they form new clans somewhere down the
river
you know they that's how they expand and
after several generations they lose
track of each other and they become
enemies because the cousins the
long-lost cousins then you don't have
two three four generations you don't
even have might you might not even have
the same language the same grunts yeah
we don't use that language here you know
I mean we have languages today they must
have had different languages of grunt
source or signals or whatever you know
and from from clan - clam it must have
changed over the ages and and so after
three four generations these sons that
left the clan they create a new clan now
they are all cousins they recognize each
other as family they've got their own
clan here and that's an enemy clan over
there and under that situation you would
think that here's an invading human who
wears clothes I'm assuming and Athos did
not wear clothes and so they have
different morphology you know obvious so
they stand out they would stand out and
they kind of maybe the smells were
different remember these guys probably
mark their territories like lions do
they mark their territory say hey I'm
coming here this is my land and for them
to say oh come on buddy let's have a
beer and you can sleep away why you
always go speak - come on buddy let's
have a beer yeah it have to be so
friendly well okay but that's that's the
point that's the point that's why
listen to a couple statements and you'll
see how how they contradict each other
here's one from green this is from the
seminal paper on the genome the actual
amount of inner bleeding between
Neanderthals and modern humans may have
been very limited given that it
contributed only one to four percent of
the genome of present-day non-africans
2010 now here's their not text this guy
says something told me though he's a
Neanderthal admixture occurred multiple
times in different non-african
populations so that we have many times
or was it a one-night stand with it
wasn't just nano though raped or
whatever a woman out there in the middle
of Noah that's how we got all our genes
from from the Neanderthals or was it a
continuous you know intermediately we'll
be friends we'll be neighbors you know
and I'm saying that you must in order to
get rid of all the manager in order for
them to becoming state you must have
generation after generation after
generation you have to have mingling you
have to have sex you can't just have a
one-night stand and say Oh from that all
the Neanderthals became extinct you see
what I'm saying a little bit I mean you
can't say okay so we had a one-night
stands now don't say you know that you
can't explain the extinction of man and
oh those were the only thing that that
they only raped one woman and you still
have to explain all right
imagine now the the Neanderthals you
know they have sex with us right two or
three guys one-night stands right rape
or consensual I don't care
the point is now they gave us a little
bit of their genes right yeah so there's
two three four a hundred guys but
there's thousands of these Neanderthals
what happened to the rest of them why
did they interbreed and continue you
know happy children we would have
Neanderthals today something that
happens so show me so we still have
explain the extinction of the
Neanderthals because two or three of
them had sex with us assuming that they
say that we were constantly
intermingling with them the only way you
can do that is what you just said
it has to be generation after generation
constantly under mainly then we could
say yeah there is to the last man to the
less the endeth oh they all had sex with
us generation can done we can explain it
but if it's just a one-night stand like
these guys are trying to say here like
yeah we had a little bit of sex there
that doesn't explain these extinct of
the animals and so that's one issue so
you know that I think it's important
because again if these guys were violent
and they killed you know animals just to
live just to eat and they engaged in
cannibalism it's very hard to believe
that a mind like that would suddenly
accept or tolerate some other species in
their hunting grounds and say oh yeah
you can go ahead and hide it you can
have sex with my wife - it can't be a
one-night thing has to be friendliness
you have to have this wildlife friendly
that's where we say okay you can join us
well how else can you explain how does
he explain that they had sex over many
generations I don't know one nights then
anyone ever talk about many generations
were they mingled and had sex they had
kids right in a day and these static
kids and eventually you know the
Neanderthal blood died out because they
were a smaller population yeah can it be
something like the humans went in there
killed all the males ah but then we're
not talking about sex see I'm talking
about that makes your sex only yeah so
how old all the male okay okay oh the
women can't be a one-night stand
see what they're saying is is there was
two guys that had sex there though 99%
of the popular
was not touched but that's no more let's
assume like humans went in there killed
all the males in just took their ways
okay let's assume them tonight be a
mixture in essence no it would be
killing yeah but you're killing all the
male you you're invoking a different
kind of mechanism you're saying that
what happened here is that we wiped out
the males that's that's your starting
point I've said you wipe out the males
and we had sex with the women it was a
chance to do that chance do that yeah
yeah they go to the next tribe over
there the next client over and they
killed the males they killed the old
lady zillion that's all they talked
about he'll make the middle all our
sleeves and sleep with their lives
that's all they talked about and they're
talking about the amount of the city and
so yeah you can you can [ __ ] many
scenarios my point here is what the
official what the papers say well I mean
they say there it was a one-night stand
from there we got her no wonder for
there's any huh yeah yeah because
there's a contradiction one says but
again it says nando thought makes you
occurred multiple times in different non
African population in other words
multiple time it was an immediate it
sounds kind of that that just means that
okay just didn't happen once a heaven
kill all the males and take their wives
okay or friendly many many generations
of you know maybe you know friendly
Omega P frame
friendly encounter do you see and I can
see a war than just taking the women you
know that you can see yeah we have
you're right that wouldn't really be
extinction to it make sure that the
extinction to war what is it extinctions
reward the other one it's hard to
believe that basil hunter gathered you
know just a rudder memory type of
hunter-gatherer would carry out a
full-fledged war where
all these class on a war I'm saying I'm
saying like quasi world where the humans
kind of go in there kill the male all
the male's of a clan and then just keep
going and killing off all the males yeah
that kind of like turns over yeah you
could I guess cut a plan like we all
right there really wouldn't be anime sir
extinction that really be more like an
invasion extinction and the worst part
about that is that we have no
mitochondrial DNA that means we
inherited no mitochondrial DNA from any
ethical mother so we would have to kill
all the women are males that's one issue
another one was a lot of is she just
spent but yeah yeah another one was
there a lack of females I'm not good
enough sleep with that human girl there
yeah and and and then the question is I
mean if this is this was right that's
one issue another one is if it's
consensual were like we're neighbors and
your wife comes over she has to me
because now in there is the other what I
don't know everything friendly neighbor
you have some sugar so she comes over if
he has sex but in the cave in front of
all the squaws all the man with all
squads they're just looking there and
saying yeah he's having sex without you
when you know I mean does that sound
realistic or vice versa you know the
Nana though going into our cave and
having sex with a woman over there you
know I think rape rape and Wars sound
like that mostly logical in the wild but
then you can't be a one-night stand it's
going to be generated
yeah the one nation and a thing is
definitely not one yeah and that's what
these guys are saying to justify the
small amount of DNA that's why they see
there is a reason for that but why do
they have to say one-night-stand to
justify it I can't they just say that it
was kind of diluted like it used to be
50/50 but then there are so many humans
that is so slowly they have that
argument as well
they've got bullet arguments but because
of what the genetics shows them when
they do regression analysis on the DNA
they say well you know the only way we
can justify this is if you know they had
like so what do we do with it
majors theorists but let me tell you
what I think
[Music]
you